we will start the meeting I'm from
everyday emergency evacuation
announcement please note that this makes
you will show me all day I'm corded
should we be required to evacuate the
building which you please leave the room
by the door to the fire escape staircase
please help both handrails in case the
stairs are wet or slippery if anyone is
unable to user stairs would they please
allow us to exit the room before they go
so far escape door where they can then
be given assistance our simply point
will be in the public car park at the
side of the Civic sweet please do not
delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings and please do not return to
the building until given permission to
do so by our council staff apologies for
absence we've got apologies from council
a counselor mrs. Mason and counselor mr.
Mason I think anybody else has got any
apologies almost all here there are no
non members attending minutes of the
meeting held on the product of april
twenty sixteen which i have got here is
everybody in agreement for these to be
signed everybody was here that makes me
read what's on those after yeah
any declarations of interest none now it
goes on to say Chairman's opening
remarks so I will try and keep it as
brief as possible first I'd like to
thank you all for attending the first
review committee meeting of this fiscal
year particularly extendable welcome to
the new members of the committee of
which there are several hope you enjoy
your time in the next 12 months
introduction to me just in case you
haven't realized to your em from my name
is counselor Jamie Burton this is glass
of wine hazelwood vice chairman for the
next year just a very quick reminder as
well just about mobile phones if they
can be switched to silent by all means
leave them on just if you could put them
on so i'll never be appreciated I know
the poll during the training session was
provided gave a very good account of
what overview and scrutiny is but just I
just wanted to briefly remind members
what we're here for we're here as a
committee to review areas that have been
suggested to us or causing concern with
respect to the operation of the council
will now be partners these concerns can
come to us from members of the public
members of this council officers all the
council partners we are able to
scrutinize decisions made by the
council's executive committee to ensure
best practice and best value is provided
at all times for the benefit of the
council tax payer we are able to make
recommendations proposed changes and
offer alternatives where appropriate and
whilst I'm taking all of the above we
should adopt a deliberative
investigative and evidence-based
approach cast aside party politics
just on a personal note looking forward
I very much look forward to working with
alongside all of you over the next
coming year I have been a review
committee before and personally found
that one of the advantages of being a
member with review committee is that you
get the opportunity to work alongside
members who you may not otherwise have
had the chance to to work on on the side
and hoped at least some of you will find
that to be a positive experience I hope
that during the course the next 12
months with guidance and Paul and the
assistance of officers portfolio holders
and others we can deliver an effective
relevant and fair review process that
demonstrates all how important overview
and scrutiny is considered here I'll DC
and how effective it can be when
delivered correctly my personal aim is
to chair this committee is the best of
my ability I'm sure that I will require
some guidance and pull some of the more
experienced members and no doubt will
make a mistake or two so I would ask you
please to bear with me as upon my feet
and thank you in advance for your
cooperation patience and understanding
last but not least I hope to be able to
chair this committee fairly and meet any
expectations you may have of me our
board members to feel equal included and
responsible and encourage all of you to
ask questions raised concerns and make
any points that you wish to make in
device aiming and then item six of their
gender is what we're here for really the
overall and at work program so you will
see from the agenda that Paul has listed
some topics and under fits best of the
hand average you at this point just for
you to explain terms in a bit more
detail gets prob just of getting out of
why they're there and here and
basically the list you see in front of
you have been suggested over the past
year and in some cases previous to that
now the thing is with the list you
haven't got to do them all you haven't
got to do any of them you could suggest
it completely different work program if
you so wish all right there's various
ones there that you might want to group
together oh my at my iPad ease and self
like connecting up so I can't see you
need a force issue if you gotta go you
gotta have you got everyone's a little
narrow but not many years um it was
attached to 30 jun yes it would England
sir hold on young I was it to Sonia
Schott was running this one buganda
space
let's joon-kook allocated to the do
yesterday that's the good day solid
right through 11 okay we've all got a
copy in front of us now with the Dennis
took we run okay they should this I
don't know if there were any extras that
any of you thought about following the
training or no well there was one thing
I like those not just in the district
council but the town council as well
raylene and trust couple of councils are
talking about the support we get
partnership the essays please or rather
than give the issues like people riding
motorcycles and the power in orlando key
turning up the National Trust guy in
bottles thrown a nobody turns up we saw
a police car when we're doing rainy
including the other day
street names as long as I please come on
a high street but they were Greeks and
breakfast sunday morning now it seems an
underlying thing here and if they can't
of work in a rule or something go I mean
but it doesn't seem to be I mean there's
a report but from another account for
this council about drugs and all that
kind of thing going on around the center
a rayleigh at the skateboard park is on
the table and now if there are all sorts
of things and it is not pleased I know
this is continued ever since the cuts
came in looking I mentioned this needed
Ward Lisa does a kind of thing you can
raise a review committee because you can
actually invite they'll cheat you guys
writing down so that we've got a lot of
partnership the critical friends over
here and so could you I know that some
of these crosses in the town but it's
been yelling because hannin it's not is
patching that other parts of the
district they say the good response this
is about Railly it's you you are the
crime and disorder committing and you
meet once a year in that format at least
once a year and usually it's the
Community Safety Partnership because
that's wrong and that's part of the
place what I would try and suggest is
you avoid turning it into what was the
neighborhood action panel the out of
style meetings where you just hammer the
place because whenever lure that doesn't
go down too well but if you want a place
to come along and talk to the committee
I mean you who is working with other
authorities I mean the other authorities
could be the place so I can see if I can
arrange for goods you've got a new place
inspector because I think inspector
forward moved on and you've got someone
else
a shame really my thing possessed he
thought this I was told it with someone
else and for the life of me I can't
think of the name yeah oh yeah yeah it's
only like the last month or something
that's it I think yeah and to introduce
himself to you I think it would have to
be more instruction just over almost
pleasantries just for my creative
process it online in town council we
have often tried to have meetings with
the local police it's extremely
difficult to arrange I don't see why
you're turning you would think so coolio
baking education alone I was didn't
really would I go through no one brother
in the funding is quite difficult well
the kitty gets stabbed over their power
confess does happen in one or something
poisoned or something sold them over
there they're going to be the poop and
it's in there any choice really just a
sale of you know what we did well as I
say we do have meetings with kids and
hockley regularly and every three months
i think last meeting I went to with a
week ago every class that's right
Israeli precisely rely on any moving to
say it again doctor surgeon for civil
the chubbies you have to be careful
you're a committee that covers whole
district and in the past when Freda's
Police inspectors have come it's become
very localized should I say and that has
caused issues now as long as it comes a
hold of the district and then I can see
if the place inspector I'll come along
and talk ctown another problem towns got
a finger for put money in for social
workers to be a location but they
shouldn't have mission creep to cover
things they're not there for and that's
that was the worry available and as I go
to the next week and I'll find out that
the guy claps across at braly now is not
a beggar nerves for the people are going
over there stained in front of these
another drink another training way and
all that goes on and use like after the
meeting that kind of thing hang on i
came i will speak to the wood on the
contacts within the council and i'll see
what we can arrange and possibly as part
of the CSP will bring along the place
that sound time i can cover the whole
you'll find a number of things on the
mound fans
purchasing a camera and I have to put
aside young to seem like you fill them
in a list after bits over there cuz they
don't investigate Patrol there anything
and that's another problem that I
getting this outside yeah that ok with
you but um I'll take that one away and
see what I can arrange cancel short come
here someone to talk about homelessness
in the council housing strategies yes
that will be our assistant director moss
and she's already said she'll come and
it would probably be september-october
copying on itself an issue already would
dolly see this or not just want to know
some more I can't get the right answers
only for now wanna talk to me I think my
only comment on homelessness would be
though it has many years on the agenda
is a topic on here it has been covered
to some degree recently I think it
wasn't was it in the last year last year
was great this year wasn't my thing
there's previously you have lobster and
that took it so the opportunity is good
in here and there are some initiatives
going on if you've got an immediate
problem have you actually spoken to
narita hold on so I was born to Andrew
budget let me know and he couldn't help
him outside no disparity was quite
negative on it but of so just what you
know me we could be in new counselors
you the older counselors my only two
years ago which I'm from quite
appreciate but he's not included in the
new counselors upon maybe to know what
the punch cheers yes I mean the only
difficulty is we are halfway through the
month now yeah the next meetings to fit
the July right and that would be
possibly pushing it
to get a report for that one and then
the next yeah we've got the awkward
break and so September will be the
following meeting and I know it's a it's
a big gap and it's just the way their
planned the calendar that's fine it's
not as if it knows it's up again that's
not in place cancel me it specifically
alone so no subject I'd like oh by the
way keep them LC news advocated resumed
under the same yeah yeah should we had
to cover that as well epic a superfood
thank you thank you cancer Stanley on
the item just before but the police or
whatever I have been in touch with I
think its current price of sending about
several items of hooliganism if you like
and other bits pieces with drugs over
its weighing park on the wonderful pole
and but with the drug day-to-day already
know if you write what is happening and
they'd rather have been happening in
isolated places so they can monitor it
so on top so and we always did in town
council we always did have the police
there on a regular basis but from her
steinberg totally was when they've got
time they only go read and and see what
they can do that means other than what
they threw his catching criminals doing
other things apart from drugs so that is
the cells of the police force then
whether or not the Commissioner or
whoever you're going to be
damn Chief Constable or whatever the
cases you will get the same answer they
have them up the start likewise we ever
got the staff my cell numbers won't
bring but that is what was Tom spoken to
me over the phone yep just to give you a
cake oh thank you intelligence the idea
of this item is to make a list don't
think that we can talk about and then
obviously to agree the list and then at
the next region start going through the
list of how we want to proceed with
these this list will obviously you know
we've got to start somewhere and hence
you're trying to get a list so the poor
command to start make some arrangements
with the people who we need to speak to
so initially our idea is just to get a
list of the number of people we want to
talk to and some of our concerns so that
at the next meeting meeting to discuss
some before either Chief Constable or
where it comes to visit us so we know
and we have a horrible idea what we're
going to talk about what begin the
present to him what questions are we
never asked in advance otherwise we're
going to look silly if we ask a chief
inspector to come down and then we all
see what we can talk about after you
making all our effort to come so I think
the general idea with this first meeting
I believe is to just make a list and
then get all the information together to
pursue those ideas you can't cancel her
quick
question support we are in relation to
the homelessness our team only I've had
someone getting contact week may use in
private rented accommodation Rebecca Lee
made hummus because the English selling
property and they've had difficulties in
them getting any assistance from from
the from Council so far and they just
asked me to see if I could look into it
for them so if you can provide me with a
contact the arkansas speak to someone
yep certainly I'll see you after it on
going back onto the social housing and
like you to fair housing and I've had
people talking to me residents in the
area that are worker that some of these
social council isn't being kept tidy so
is there someone thats opened how do we
follow up that with because if the
social housing amongst the new houses
they're being put up I'm referring
particularly to the christmas tree film
and this instant incident but there's
obviously going to be other thousand
yeah with regard to the social housing
for the various developments it's not as
straightforward as saying oh it's rhi
because they might not have the social
housing on that development the housing
department will know who controls that
part of that area who's got those houses
and we'll be able to point you in the
right direction hood sore too okay so
okay i'll provide you with contacts
afterwards
canceling cooking disabled facilities
groans another 23 years supposed to be
more ago the whole system was very bad
and killed at the time had a lot of
conversations with the vin portfolio
holder to try and get things moving
forward can we have a report of health
and stand at the moment and how long the
items have been on the books yeah he's
only am again get pretty be
september-october it's the same ad as
homeless so what I will try and try and
do is arrange for them both on the same
night so she deals with the model at the
same time but it in two different items
okay begin cancel school and Essex
highways reading speed minutes see ya
little bit potholes and highway speed
limits have been on there for I was
probably been on for a couple years at
least councillor who I didn't mention is
a meeting that camp earlier on thursday
i think all councillors district level
of big invitrogen well they would have
had i think on emails yesterday probably
driving with Sam again something under
there was sorry human it was on the
members burger nothing will previously i
think it's come back on the members
bulletin because they didn't have enough
interest yes um police photos you
afternoon thursday after account
according joseph 2 p.m. i'm not sure
really pretty really is once in every
month we can set it up and into council
johnson was no quiero do 2 kten
horses in training but it caches we
lighten to ya the other way now whether
I could get in arka-dal sis if you'll
come down I don't know because he's
always done on a county birth thank you
it very properly get canceled Harold M
we would I think so wrong ok I will make
some inquiries there's no cows right now
it is the young deputy cabinet member of
basics sorry right now it is the deputy
champion group and kissing's okay now
I'm ready for God think is what could
have come again yeah i knows ask
guaranteed try but i got lengthen it but
i will go back so i can do a copy me
only yeah female yeah okay Glennis
ethical and Chancellor Seeger provides
us with a breakdown of the proof that
the county councillors doing in regards
to roll bottles etc every two weeks and
transyl are used to yeah that was like
well obviously that obviously you might
help some of your residence because i
know they do for me up sometimes and say
what's happening so so so so by looking
at that list I can tell and what to
predicted time is going to take what
they actually doing and some of the
times it's like they put many new
cabling which obviously we have no
control over but at least you can tell
the residents that they are you know
there's going to be traffic lights is
predicted for a month and the National
agree to put in some new cabling which
we have no control over and it at least
they know what's happening and they know
what's going to take place rather than
just as a set
traffic lights appear one day and
massive a mass amount of traffic
everywhere blocking the roads and
obviously porous to know what's going on
so that it does help in some respect a
quite group of that but that was a good
question asked for I didn't say full
house I think the speaking that's what
are much more interesting and for why
she mentioned palms are the second sorry
I was a young people thinking about
speaking morning because Connick Duffy
oh he's quite right we do get the things
from yeah are the little drops your
trunk contact come here counselor right
hand can I was giving other members of
got any additional topics that they
would like to raise at this stage to add
to this the list that's already on the
agenda I mean additional topics that
anybody has at the moment okay can I
just yes last year the committee heard
from the cocoa commissioning groups
around health and the Care Act I've been
asked whether the committee want
anything on health this year I mean at
the moment the clinical commissioning
groups I believe the discussing hubs and
John saw town centres where patients
will be sent for various minor
procedures etc and the hospital was also
talking about rationalization and
various bits about ine and that are you
interested in him from any health
speakers this year because if you are I
can possibly get someone down from the
CCJ orphaned are still to talk about
those issues I think that would be am
probably quite important and interesting
I think anything that's where that these
changes in legislation or new life
structural changes that may have a
bearing on us as a district would be
able to be able to look at yeah okay
I'll see what does it feel to be more
specific as well I think yet perhaps too
much for district is heavily rely on
South End hospital in particular yes yes
on a black which is kind of very topical
at the moment for reasons which how I'm
good if it can be mainly bit more
targeted at that that may be again an
idea again I know the chief exec from
South in hospital goes to the health and
well-being board and that's who my
contact was saying one possibly come
down and be prepared torches so
certainly then you could hear from the
main person about the problem south end
oh god okay it's okay sighs it's just
what excuse me one other thing is though
you interact with parish councils that
are led that can be put onto the list
when we first article you had a talk
from the 15 Alcide one by one yeah
nothing parish councils needed to hear
all we heard that can be integrated with
this something look at what we've
regards to the health we don't have to
take a little don't know why you're so
secure our relationship district answer
relationship with parish and tell kelsey
none of that can be the journal beery up
through the r-la see don't Lee you say
they've got with the parishes of God
rochford hundred matings is also Harris
summits I know Nick Khan has been
discussing the parishes what they
actually want from the district Royal
Council because I was at a meeting last
week about that that side of it
so we will see what we can do on that
that's right as always good yeah yeah
there is some discussion we're trying to
look at who's the best person to talk to
the parishes and how we disseminate
information to them I'm not being Roger
Parish Council sometimes I feel a little
bit left out yeah yeah okay um broader
these room if I jump down the list of a
little bit to the budget process of
consultation we have the section 151
officer penciled in for next month to
talk about treasury management as we
have three treasury management reports a
year and i just wondered if that would
be a chance to sort of deal with that
the budget process of consultation with
the budget process and some of the older
members will know starts really from
july and and sort rolls on most of the
year so it's better getting early with
any budget sort of comments and work
rather than later chance for what I
think that would be a blogger I think
this the July meeting would be ideal for
that I think sickly around the
consultation star represents one of the
areas which was trying to look at in
previous years and already got got very
far with it okay and i think the
processes will work well before it
really starts yeah okay so there any
real areas you want me to cover their
getting to cover the carpet obviously
the consultation
we consultation mythology with residents
I think and the probe I think the
process has changed anyway since this
was originally put on the world claim
right yeah I think miss but overview of
the process 1 / okay it was I didn't
have one other topic i was going to rise
by suspended everybody on thursday first
which is a new topic and but i am
conscious that it we could or could
possibly be focused and raised i am
aware of that normal and that's with
regards to the air quality management
areas that have been created which does
at the moment i believe there is only
the monorail e but it wasn't so much to
do with brainwaves monthly more to do
with the procedures at the council the
areas are monitored but we don't really
see it awful lot from the magis want to
know how effective the monitoring of
those are the general sounds thing from
the public is that it's getting worse
and I but I do believe possibly that
something's coming forward is imminently
about it now it's going to ask you to
check on that okay I will I was but I do
also i think it's going to be surgically
possibly has the potential to be shifted
across the district yelling other areas
could be infected soon and there's a lot
air quality monitoring domain and I when
I used to ruin good their stations think
more lies retreated talks that there was
possibly going to be an area in rochford
that was going to fall under the air
quality because the Equality of all
right in which case they'll have to do a
report back but its features that i was
looking more at you know we it is being
monitored I think the area was set up a
few years ago gets once at every six
months but the levels of pollution and
I'm not really common knowledge the
residents that all living in these areas
are completely oblivious to the fact
that they live in these areas so could
also be how the council gets the message
for are they doing enough to inform
residents okay of these areas if they're
important tourism yeah oh that's not
from mine I can speak to the person as
deals with it and I'll get them knocking
just a comment yeah could come along and
talk about it counsel Lucas good um took
that monitoring but where's the council
can do nothing to affect it can we no no
it's purely a monitoring exercise from
my understanding but it would be useful
for the counselors trashy know how it's
done and then possibly the residents can
t do all these figures part on the
government's over let's say that could
be part from nobody read I know there
are monitors undertaken I don't know
what happened information the residents
aren't aware of it I don't quite know
the limits of what as a district council
we can or cannot do surgical ask for
help yeah the situation because i think
i read in the one was only 2014 that the
council has to submit in addition to the
edge muttering has to formulate and
submit a plan with regards to how
they're going to reduce the air quality
soon i'm not aware of what that plan
says or if one's been drafted and again
I I had her confidence that I mean at
the moment this is mainly with in raleys
high street all the way down to 38 127
eastwood road partly way down to the
station along hakavod but do you
understand I'm I could be wrong that
there is an area mulford and that's
possibly getting designated a similar
area because the air quality has become
so poor it's perry county thing because
london did I am so tired of vehicles but
you have to actually saw a county yeah
we as a district council we have a
monitoring role we have to declare that
area just imagine later on the probably
affect policy zone but we'll get we'll
get the expert in the council to come
down and talk about it and scrub
potentials political amazon wow there's
a lot of some issues around there comes
a hook yeah probably quite important to
find out about how this season monitored
how it's used or how in what way its
report it because I know that it's been
brought up in arguments to do with
planning and development and as part of
arguments and evidence in relation to
traffic congestion you know
problems with their quality etc so it be
I think it's quite important to
understand that because that then feeds
into other other fingers keep my cancer
standing on it just going to mention
something Simmons world so it's been
said that can we at the same job
obviously he's going to talk to us about
the pollution on what have you booked
and what he will use some bring
reference of because I know there was
some couple years ago when they did the
fondant figures and gave us an idea but
I don't know if I cancel have had those
up-to-date figures so perhaps if you
bring those along as well yeah thank you
ok any other members got any additional
topics or can we have a look at the
existing ones and maybe go through yeah
okay yeah okay working with other
authorities I will decide I have briefed
you spoken to pull about few of these
not with any new literature's to get
better idea why then sanded I mean
worked with other authorities is is
fairly self-explanatory I think it has
the potential to be what I think is what
a wide topic personally and I think it
may have to be condensed I need to get
something constructive out of it we
obviously work with alongside a lot of
authority you know is there a particular
authority what here it would we be
looking at that sort of thing I don't
know if there was anything more specific
but at the time I don't think there was
enough no just RDCs relationship with
other authorities but I think that could
potentially be quite consider
all perfect Attila ban it was going to
comment sarcastic like a social yeah I
mean as has been previously mentioned
about perhaps getting someone from the
local police ice obviously falls under
this but perhaps maybe if firm if it was
more like working with other authorities
like ourselves that is my understanding
here where where its cooperation between
authorities and to do with obviously we
share work etc amongst the authorities
also fits in the planning thing under
the duty of cooperation etc so that that
in itself is probably a topic and and in
relation to perhaps police health fire
and all that that's that's probably a
separate Sunday chance official so who
else was that we'd already sent to
another Authority about the place but
that's you know um trying to make
conclusions now we was on that one I
just think it knows it's humid it is on
the way on the less effect I mean at the
council or the authority work with a
number of our councils all the time
where we're always going out to other
councils etc at the moment we haven't
got anything that I know of him in the
that's sort of being suggested but you
could just leave it on the work plan you
haven't got a maker to suit in chennai
on that one you've got plenty of others
at the moment to keep you busy I mean
it's a bit like the one beloved potholes
has been on there for two years and you
know it's been one we haven't been at
the shift gone move and get any action
on last year I did or we did it was last
year we tried to get someone down the
night was just told blindly no that
would never come down and never his head
that was County telling me now I think
as councils were no potholes are
probably the biggest of our all of our
residents and it's probably one of the
things that we can do very little about
other than badger county councils and
it's kind of biscuit I think there is a
session sometime ago that we took over
that work from county if a fabulous I
don't know if that is possible still I
personally don't know how kind of look
at me now look boys see if he knows
anything about the kids but as there are
discussions I'll no other kill district
not have done that karthi's morning from
memory has done it which probably isn't
surprised consilience council event
that's right here there is talk nothing
through the local highways penland might
be buddies but there's lots of issues
around to via the moment why we had to
take all more people than we want to be
the one I think that's the issue of the
moment well that was under the yes she
has the previous deputy leader was
dealing with that lovely that's one
thank you I've said the impression of
counselor bastard didn't like that idea
because of who would be responsible if
there was an accident because it was not
done properly etc is because the county
got an overall insurance policy to cover
anything they do that go wrong we'd have
to take out our own cover and the
consequences as I could be catastrophic
but that's why I believe they were
issued Council of glass in defense of
why the county does it because this will
all control of one authority rather than
bits of DC area median your own thing
and control absolute chaos trust me over
a year or so ago suggested the very
council starts to do something as well a
parrot car passed out other than this
year because of the he didn't feel sort
of the ramifications of a match against
and all that new data payout indeed Ron
chose your fortune katzenback one yeah
there is a sound there isn't moving and
to supply moving stuff down to parishes
I think no necessary regards potholes
but I know slightly off offline but
mostly the similar sort of thing is to
do with them some work in relation to
the maintenance of footpaths and things
like that there's been too
come from people from counties gone down
to parishes and pair of shoes have got
the option getting involved with
maintenance or perhaps and that so this
is obviously part of our a general sort
of like idea or scheme to try and push
down some responses further down into
into parishes when the Paris hoppip our
Chancellor's been doing it for 25 years
I think my initial thoughts about
potholes is that we are going to be as a
review committee going to be heavily
reliant on Essex to actually get
anywhere with a review and I think
probably taking guidance from others I
think we're going to really struggle to
get any cooperation from a six that's
fair or not but that's I think that's
the general consensus I think it's only
a very simple model but if you have a
risk analysis of ever an accident or
father hold a few roads are in the
nation as loads of potholes their
insurance company must be having the
jitters because they're everywhere
there's no proper focus people I mean
there's a cover rose on think I was a
thing it's only a lot a crater problem
there's not even any paint bandit that's
been raised but not by me raise volume
ward it's just getting worse and worse
at the end of it it always business but
Papa taught tennis ball and the
Overlander one take a photograph all
very nice but if it was efficiently
properly managed you have fewer piles
and fewer chances out an accident the
risk is eighth and that's that's the
thing for the moment they've admitted
for seven years they've not been looking
after our estate ropes probably not
spend very much money on in this
district and north of the county of
those who the devil entered our
experiment was there yet can always been
off the whole world
hermanson asleep I'm getting less about
the troubles of potholes I think it's a
little bit into this can have some
hobbies I know these are topics to have
been some of them have been here for a
couple years and I think it's a
committee we almost there's an
obligatory we don't think the demon on
the list for yeah I mean we know it i
don't remember i think we just i'm good
just dismiss it or we're gonna just
dismiss anything i don't think that's
the case at all but i think when you are
quiet relying on another party in order
to the progress something that we might
raise as a beauty it could be a strong
when it could be that the petitioner
could be a waste of committee members
time to spend a long time trying to get
somebody from SS come down to try and
get an answer to get responses to get
statistics it could be a real slob
probably television either through
taking a goddess report on this island
are you think there's nothing I think
Vaughn the answer I've got no you're go
to Georgia it won't marry Fujio five or
six of them coming so I would just leave
it on the list at the moment I think I'm
planning conditions and scheme of
delegation rdc time protocol and then
more set was around the Constitution
what's actually in the Constitution
because the scheme of delegation comes
from the Constitution and if you look
further down suitability and relevance
of the Constitution also sort of falls
within that it's probably a project that
would need to be done why you from me
evenings as a task and finish group
or a project team it was suggested by
camp counselor mr. Mason previously you
might want to leave it on the list and
titties on over castle Mason mr. Mason
who's keen to work on that as well yeah
obvious they were ones that so forward
I'd leave it on the list until next
month when it's back and see if he wants
to push for a project team an hour I
think really like you say that because
that's got to do Constitution it's
almost superseded by his one's own yeah
yeah hope so mr. Queen yet has look like
in was moves the last for a review of a
capital Constitution I don't think it
has been but probably about at least
five years if not more he is June so
it's right for the overall yeah would it
be the whole on tickets not a whole
Constitution or would it it would be the
area to be concerned thing I think Terra
leaves the whole Constitution but there
are certain areas of concern with it
within it which are very ambiguous in
their interpretation i think is on
probably suggest is best left to when
councillor john mason returns
I don't think it's something we've
stopped before no its return anyone else
then that's it I mean I couldn't get a
project team are reviewing the whole
Constitution see any of them an epic
task I don't know that I think basically
the first million that their team would
have to then sort of drama bot male what
areas of Constitution cause the most
concern and go from there it's it's
trying to scope it done project planning
and that would probably it probably run
the hold hold the municipal you in the
ipod coming home mrs. and the council's
housing saturday we that's something
that's also good right again yet tonight
and i'll i'll arrange for the assistant
director to come and talk to the
committee both on that and the disabled
facility grants beneath it i mean i've
already spoken to her she's already
searching prepared to come it just only
members aware there is a known as
exactly which general assistant virtue
is recently which the naughty goes
completely just prior to the election
for a memory possibly yeah so that might
be worth a look thank you LOL friday
sure which are available so it could
actually be reviewed from a different
angle wake up we could be with you in
two yeah they're newly written there's a
newly rich one which one there when this
is first of all of us yeah cancel again
i think they saw was under trying
legislation we've got the new housing
built in past and however from a meetin
I'd yesterday and the planning officers
haven't had information as to how it's
going to directly affect council policy
in relation to how affordable housing
policy and the what's the the new the
new term it's the discounted housing
isn't it that's parted that counting the
noogler just started off that's it they
don't know how it's going to affect our
policy with regard to athletic foxing
whether it falls within their or outside
of it the informations from the new
legislation as yet to be shut down to us
so it would be hardly relevant in
relation to so that as this information
starts to come out okay okay again sable
City sconce you just touched on that you
gently yeah you just rejoin them just
because they're not human the ID that
deals with that side of it would also
come down and talk about that I know
she'd been working on the EF Jays
because yes a couple of years ago that
before they did improve but if you look
at the balance busy scorecard the
figures and the time taken have gone
down again sorry taken longer but
there's been some work on that and she's
quite happy to comment on an update
members on there okay thank you green
waste collection right green waste
collection what was part of the
budget proposals from last year about
income generation etc I was talking to
the ad today about it um I think at the
moment there is a report being prepared
as to whether they really want to pursue
this or not and it might be that he is
going to suggest that the whole if it
does get sort of agreed that we're going
to go ahead I think he's possibly gonna
push it the review committees way to
look at it this is a small have been you
know a small green bill big if you want
to be enough to pay I think 40 bumper
yeah but it's there's no certainty in my
mouth members are go doing that very got
any more good idea of when you're
important it's going to be fine I'll
talk to I understand it you might be
before the summer recess we've got about
the glades are reportedly yeah it'll be
a council report because it all doubts
but we can't really do anything no
there's no point do think there's no
point we don't know whether we're going
to go ahead with the system and explore
it or not but if they do go ahead I
decide to go ahead he might push it to
the review committee to actually explore
how it could work
and come up with ideas I think that'd be
quite contentious issue videos I think
it'd be good yeah does this come under
also as a side issue from the budget
process and consultation thing as well I
my friends although it was married it's
on yeah it was even in the old days when
they first introduced the bends and that
the system we use now I think was about
two or three years of sub kameez
deciding the how it was going to work
before it's actually introduced to try
and make sure was introduced smoothly
and worked if you remember there was
some teething problems but it did get
sorted out fairly quickly and they did
that the system was considered a lot
better than the south end system with
bags etc as it's known oh yeah and now
south end have had to go to boxes and
separate various things so it does take
a lot of time and you will find that'll
be a an area probably of interest to all
members as to how that's going to work
there was a program on attorney a couple
of days ago about how various councils
around the country I've reviewed their
wasting and by changing it to smaller
bins bigger bins nor bins move dance
better than our little guess that all
these e typically happen or didn't
happen if you'll get one of the four
things yeah it's going to look stuff you
I don't they don't take you [ __ ] out
you don't it's quite interested you
don't yeah but it will wait I think what
I think makes people I should advise you
to wait until the council have made
their decision whether they're going to
go ahead and and then go from there okay
so I'll just leave that on your list at
night maybe a technology solution you
know like what small may as well be the
things empty you've got something loops
can of our code is home I think some
kids like a big day and they've got
because they even why them if and then
you know how much but then it was the
Big Brother approach and some councils
used it wrongly and beads papers made we
don't people smoking at them whoa it up
and then you get your kids to snooping
tell you fill out my penguin grass when
the grass is growing in the winter so
many things I only quit for an empty bin
are for you you know how I ain't even if
you guys I'm only live the wife so I'm
not going to philly up with a local will
sound thing you have to do is skinny
one of the reasons why they did consider
smaller business because I said people
only a small proportion of it been but
there's a lot of people who do a lot of
God and I've got be gods and with
filling up I must admit I feel up mine
quite regularly and we've done is done
so i would have to be do Peter for a
panther you do you may been but after
the sovereign is helpful in with her
there's lots of for and against so
cancel stomach but I was just going to
reiterate what you say you know is that
take bananas a single person just
cutting the grass front bag you get bail
you get full bit where you've done it
obviously it'll pack down but I just
wonder if the what revenue we get in
from taking this amount that we've taken
at the moment and if we're going to go
to small events is that going to be a
the revenue will it cover all the
aspects of delivery basically so well I
guess that would be the point of a kind
of reporters decide whether or not yes
things are yeah that I'm saying if they
if anything that we call comes in that I
think you know we got you to the report
that counts are going exactly to get ya
before you actually get took at the
schemes as pops think it was the idea of
that was at the end of the day is that
we are looking for more money for the
capsule so where can we go down that
line we're going to go down and looking
for more money we need to open up the
doors instead of closing the doors to a
smaller area we need to open the doors
up to a bigger enterprise so we can take
on more and we thought the logistics of
thousands of
we'll try to get there to dump lost if
they don't want to pay before we
could've day another these and really is
a group your pollution then one week and
I approach I'm nothing oh I think that's
like best ones join for calendars don't
you see the parent solution sorry
Carlton green waste is done suitability
of evidence relevant of the Constitution
I think we've agreed that will just hold
on til ya cancel my sins back changing
the council's working places I think
it's something else that cancel my son
yeah adjusted basically it's where the
council's changed various departments
that are doing sort of work and then
counselors don't know and don't know who
to approach at the right time i would
suggest leave it on there until next
month when the council Mason's back and
can explain it better budgeting recent
habitation in touch from yeah that I'm
going to get and I'm going to get Rob to
come down to talk about that one and so
I mean obviously goes on to methodology
on the agenda yeah but do you want us to
a green you've already agreed yeah as
we've gone through it and i'll leave
that one minute and methodology is
usually how you're going to do these
things but we've actually dealt with it
as we've gone through so we won't need
to cover that that side of it tonight um
the next next month you'll see with the
agenda there'll be a work plan but one
look very much like that
and we tell me what's planned for your
meeting full of what's going on and
you'll get an update each month with the
agenda and it will be able to be
discussed each mating it's alright so
that it gives it it's a running a update
and if there's anything you want to add
if you sort of come away from the means
at know anything I wish I'd said that
and I wish I'd got that on there you've
still got a chance okay try to do with
this in case you want to carry on to go
to the button yeah do the key decision
document.write and your copy of the key
decision document got you space where we
began to do with the junction cancers
were named to matrices and what they
don't be a difficult at the moment I
want to get through whoever you need to
get through because we haven't had a fun
than that I don't see anything that
tells me who does what footbed to do
what is that something that
is that saying we're going to itouch you
don't know about the transition but I
was like you let me know I just assign
mommy make don't know about every kind
remembering that only God members coitus
what does emma skye have phone numbers
yup no no I don't know what they don't
exactly what their I know what they're
they're wrong knees if you got me and
you know their title but not actually on
actually help them fundamental physician
is what they do didn't that they cross
over to this and that they do that or do
ever go speak to somebody else because
update which way to make a lot of fun
interview yeah hmmm azhar yeah thanks a
lot as well the council is all blocking
abilities yeah comes land is changing
the new members of started other people
of go in and sometimes I know I know me
ring 318 111 yeah and the lady at
reception I just say to it I need to
speak to somebody but this tree telling
you and you do it and she would call for
knives to spritz on which wonder what
big program is in its different aspects
of it go to different people under the
same section so if i don't feel have one
person will do it all and that's why
this it gets a bit confused here and
though it does get compute
he does and they not be of the day 30 a
flair for the got my voicemail would you
love speak sir sir but I don't know if
he does that does she like come in on
the delivery will have a nap didn't say
I'm sorry man I don't do that for yeah
well you know don't waste your time on
the boat I'm living out nice I mean I'm
sorry counselor cuz I'm i totally agree
with you because you're trying to put a
face to a job to a phone number to help
residents with if therefore issues to
try and contact someone in the council
it took me probably 35 millions to try
and track down the right person that I
need to speak to me now if we had a list
of the people and their position and a
phone number or an email number I have
to get this and go I need to speak to
mr. dude our highways blah blah blah
I've got it straight away okay okay
could that be something that we perhaps
incorporate into that particular review
where it is changing the council's
working practices and I hacked looking
at the trap of some form of what would
breach between here although i think
probably they're going to need it sooner
rather than later because you're getting
rest of the choir is all the time I'll
see what I couldn't I've talked to
member services tomorrow Thank You
Michelle whatever conversation we'll see
if there's something we can produce like
that would help you put in it possibly
it should have been down the induction
yes because which I haven't lit up so
everybody was
introduced for what part of what they
did what job there was what this is I
need the high level and not that there
was there was nothing but well there's a
list of everybody that you need to get
in contact with if you need to get in
contact oh people yeah okay yeah because
you really no need to know what what
their roles on what it is yeah okay I
see one no mom no it's not that good
because people would covered in
carolinas yeah just got okay fellow they
could go back to the key key decision
just on him okay see y'all got a copy in
front of you as i said on the training
this covers any items of expenditure
over 50,000 pounds that is not already
on the budget and what would affect two
or more wards okay there there are two
criteria for it to be a key decision yes
mine mr. Chairman I don't know if your
chair would be interested in our skin
them the assistant director more the
green waste isn't on Liam the decision
block before it all tweaked he's gone
council respectful pounds business
direct I thought because we've said that
good about you oh I tell you is going on
cancer Oh obviously if counts who are
making the decision it will not be on
this it's only those that are going to
be except for very own homes all right
number 116 the planning policy evidence
base that one living with you now yeah
yeah but we'll skip that for a sec this
decision actually expires for calling at
midnight tonight
you have already seen the report and the
decision came out the last Tuesday to
members so that's done yeah well I
hadn't contacted to say me who's done
yeah Diggy expires tonight did ponder as
to whether it was in something worth
discussing big brawl dobut and spoke to
counselor mr. Mason about it and he was
yet a similar perspective that terms of
perhaps you probably arguing against or
trying to pump it it would be very very
difficult right ok the next 13 16 the
environmental health service plan
outlines objectives for the regulatory
functions of the team this one's an
annual one in its produced annually and
just explains what they're going to do
how they're going to do it etc and
you'll see that one each year or should
see each year on the key decision
document doesn't really change doesn't
know it's it's pretty much the same
report every year just how they're going
to go back doing their work for they
come up to stop premature obviously this
is block the phone hydrating and and as
you know that in the past some of the
food hygiene hasn't been up to scratch
is that going to be a Brady to some
extent or are we still going to go all
the twice-yearly thing I mean I don't
know whether this that meant isms or not
but um
when he puts out the bell per our plan
of how their how they're going to do it
and then that's what he's saying there
so they actually do that yet the if if
you're unhappy with what they're
planning by then you can certainly have
thought that we haven't had it on so you
know so what we do get we will get it
again you'll get a report first yeah
we've been in at least five working days
full paths before the actual decision
comes out before the perio how that
makes the decision and if you've got
concerns with the report and what's in
it you can contact the report author and
ask them at that time we can review it
or is it an individual review because I
other gods we do that sleeper pajamas
that's something we could okay it's very
important for you even when the
decisional major they're called it here
cool I don't know when you say call you
you can only caught me in a decision or
you can do pre decision scrutiny IE
before the decisions made you could get
the officer to come and talk to you
about it now if you've got concerns over
there I can have a word with mind how it
and see if you'll come along to the July
meeting and talk to you about in roles
that actually its bottom view as
individual members that talk to Martin
harwich there as well to see if there
are if your concerns of warranty before
you bring it to a committee
there's no probably took anything with
many of the audiences as when something
is it you could you could find him out
tomorrow I've seen this on the Cape
decision document oh don't concerns but
it can just explain to me more death and
he will go yeah okay believe you're
happy with that fine it's not find me up
and tell me and I'll I'll getting along
to the committee to to talk to the wing
committee wanted to come to the
committee open this company instance
would that be prior to publish and pull
yeah I think see them actually find that
yeah that's a guideline isn't it I can
go back tomorrow and saving before you
make the decision or the report and push
it charlie can you just get the
presentation yet come and talk and
remembers so do you want to talk to mind
first well I dunno does anybody else is
anybody else who all the good part with
you or ball I think be an idea of what
Bollinger said when he's prepared this
report we can bring it in and so we can
do you look at it it's got many people a
day also subscribe that depends on the
continent yeah i SPECT amounting
somebody get too involved with images to
cover pointers to or even if you but the
reason that I starting this is may drop
a lot of its members before a lot of it
is six without offers welcome a lot of
you say about you you know their father
we're what the law is it all sounds oh
yeah and I know the number
as I run them out they've been very
effective and they got down and look if
they thought in his right or on the
user's top tip over they carry on so I
must have been a very good normally but
they have they only carry out what the
law says they can and can't do so it's
pretty much written in stone all of it
isn't but i'll spit to marketing
tomorrow and see us what what okay if
you please and then the last 14 16
another one of Martin's insect
identification service and at the moment
they do an informal insect
identification work which does take up
some time it's mainly from what I
understand around the false widow
spiders but people are concerned and
they call them out about various things
than saying you know can you identify
these insects etc it's been put forward
as a possible area the Weaver cease
doing or we actually make a charge for
we already charged for pest control and
that's why this report is about its
spelling out whether they should charge
or just cease doing them that service
but we haven't had an important no no
you haven't necessarily ball hitting
cancer stem so it that is just for one
so I'd rather than the umbrella of pest
control yeah well you're so again that
would be just separate from there as
control at the moment is an informal
thing where we're contacted and asked to
identify various insects from pictures
whatever and they're Samwell the reader
going to make a charge for it or cease
doing that informal service
Bosley Ebola virus has come about isn't
it and lots of people are concerned to
the news my new for this is it's not
force without spiders where the fresco
same people have been bitten and the
blokes lost his leg and ya didn't even
do a Google search on false widow spider
you'll see notes and if you can cause it
to get neck grab that be the next one is
that mosquito infestation yes we can pop
yeah yeah touch LT olympics haven't been
hotter wind around look that good one
the very resilient ok so members happy
with the kids even any questions know
that in Britain you left in America but
ok so that is in the meeting at age 44